the word arbitrage sounds very fancy but
it's actually a very simple idea it's
really just taking advantage of
differences in price on essentially the
same thing to make risk-free profit so
let's just think about it a little bit
let's say in one part of town there's
some type of a market let's say it's a
market for apples and let's say in that
market apples sell for make up some some
price let's say that Apple's in that
market sell for $1 an Apple one dollar
per Apple and let's say in another part
of town you have another market another
markets literally a fruit market and in
that other part of town apples sell for
apples sell for a dollar 50 an Apple a
dollar 50 an apple so how could you take
advantage and that we're going to assume
that these apples are completely
identical apples how could you take
advantage in this price difference on
these identical things to make a
risk-free profit well ideally you would
want to sell apples in the more
expensive market where you could get a
dollar fifty per Apple and you would
want to buy apples in the less expensive
market where you can get them for a
dollar per Apple and that's exactly what
you would do you would go does this
market over here you would buy apples
let's say you buy ten apples ten apples
for ten dollars and then you would go
maybe you know ride your bicycle a
couple of blocks to the other market
over there and you would sell your ten
apples so this is buy ten apples for ten
dollars and then you would sell you
would sell those ten apples you would
sell those ten apples for $15 $15 and so
you would make an immediate risk free
profit of five dollars you're buying for
ten selling at five and you can just
keep doing that over and over again and
on as many on every trip as many apples
as your bicycle can carry you'll just
continue to make money and so this is
what arbitrage is and just to imagine a
side effect if someone did this enough
then what it would do is it would
increase the supply of apples he
so the supply would increase in this
market and on this market the demand
would increase because there's someone
who just keeps buying from this market
and selling into that market
so it's eventually going to happen when
demand increases the price will go up in
this market the price will go up in this
market and when the supply increases in
this market the price will go down so in
theory the more you do this the more
that you're going to make these prices
come closer to each other and eventually
you won't be able to make any profit at
all but while there's this great
discrepancy you have an opportunity for
arbitrage